it was one month ago that a Freight
Train derailed and Spilled toxic
chemicals in East Palestine Ohio at a
public meeting last night people from
the town confronted the railroads
operator understandably as Roxanna
severe reports it got very heated at
times
I'm stuck
no one's coming to save us with pleas
for help I'm begging you by the grace of
God please get our people out and
stories of illness
numbness in their mouth no missing their
fingers around 200 residents in East
Palestine directly confronted a
representative of Norfolk Southern for
the first time last night at a public
meeting erupting with frustration and
anger
[Music]
days after the disaster
Melissa Blake told us she was diagnosed
with bronchitis due to chemical fumes
how are you feeling now same what are
you scared of
and get more sick under pressure from
residents the EPA has now ordered
Norfolk Southern to test the derailment
site for dioxins toxic chemical
compounds that can cause cancer EPA
monitors have not detected any volatile
organic compounds above levels of health
concerns
[Applause]
so far Crews there have shipped more
than 2 million gallons of liquid
Wastewater and about 1400 tons of solid
waste to seven disposal sites in four
states
among them is one just south of the
disaster Zone in East Liverpool Ohio
many here say they don't want the
Hazardous Waste either so you're worried
that this drinking water from this River
will be contaminated yeah that's my
biggest concern we already know that it
created a huge problem in East Palestine
the EPA says it could take about three
weeks to finish collecting data to see
if there are dioxins at the derailment
site but EPA officials say early testing
data suggests there is low probability
of dioxin contamination Tony
all right Roxanna thank you very much